[Music]
the Royals make everything about the
holidays look more regal but do they
have any traditions we can relate to ET
breaks down how the Royals do Christmas
were their family traditions you had to
explain I think one of the biggest I
know of and every family is his complex
as well so no she's done an absolutely
amazing job last year was Megan's first
Christmas with the Royal fan he wasn't
yet an official member and this year we
have good reason to believe that her mom
Doria Ragland will join the regal
celebrations and break royal protocol
again but these breaks aside the Windsor
household is all about following holiday
tradition whole family would gather
together and the crane would host
everybody
Carolyn Rob the former personal chef to
Princess Diana Prince Charles and the
boys gave us an inside look at some of
the Royal Family's Christmas traditions
past and present it's very traditional
they have sort of handing over of
presents quite often on Christmas Eve
the Royals leave treats for Santa and
his reindeer a practice that makes them
seem just like us I always remember
Princess Diana in the the run-up to
Christmas and coming into the kitchen
and little bits and pieces that she
needed for them and creating reindeer
food to leave out for them and of course
they needed carrots for the reindeer for
Christmas night and a couple of mince
pies and all those things some people
leave a glass of sherry for Santa Claus
some people leave a glass of milk it
depends what your inclination if it's
Christmas morning seems pretty standard
Christmas morning I think they will have
children have their stockings and then
the Queen would spend some time with all
the members of staff the Christmas I was
there I've met the Queen on Christmas
morning and she gave me a gift so that
takes up about an hour and a half of her
time on Christmas Day which I always
think is incredible that she will stop
and do that on Christmas Day itself the
family go to church in the morning and
then they go back to Sandringham house
for an for a lunch and to watch of
course the Queen's speech in the
afternoon and then really the family are
left to enjoy themselves too to play
games and on Boxing Day there is that
famous shoot that most of the senior
members of the family and take part in
most senior members except for me be
Harry reports claim the prince will skip
this tradition for the second year in a
row to stand in solidarity with the
Duchess of Sussex who isn't a fan of
hunting
what about Royal Christmas me on
Christmas lunch is very traditional so
it would be roast turkey with all the
trimmings of stuffing and sausages and
chipolata sausages a roast ham as well
Brussels sprouts roast potatoes
cranberry sauce bread sauce gravy all
those things Christmas afternoon they'd
have tea so Christmas cake and scones
ginger biscuits those kind of friendly
traditional ginger Christmas things and
then in the evening just a cold meal and
part of the reason for that was so the
chefs could at least have Christmas
night off and not be doing another big
meal another really cool thing is from
the Queen down the Royals don't let
anything go to waste the next couple of
days interestingly like like every other
family they would have a lot of
leftovers so they'd be cold turkey cold
ham the day after turkey pie turkey soup
so they're all very thrifty and nothing
goes to waste and they really don't have
hugely sort of extravagant and luxurious
tastes at the end of the day the Royals
aren't that different from us when it
comes to Christmas at least
[Applause]
[Music]